[Música]
lo aquí el embaucador se retorcía bajo
el implacable yugo de thor la noche
anterior mientras los demás dioses
dormían se escabulló en la habitación de
la esposa de toro shift y le cortó su
hermosa cabellera le parece una broma
graciosa en el momento pero por ella
todo estaba dispuesto a romperle todos
los huesos lo que debía pensar cómo
solucionar lo que había hecho sin
embargo quien podría reemplazar el
inigualable cabello de shift dorado como
un campo de trigo en verano los enanos
estos legendarios herreros podrían
fabricar lo que fuera entonces lo que se
dirigió a prisa a su reino en lo
profundo de las montañas
incluso antes de llegar el astuto de lo
que tramaba como conseguiría que los
enanos hicieran lo que él quería
decidió que su mejor alternativa era
enfrentar a dos familias
primero visitó a los habilidosos hijos
de ewald y les dijo que sus rivales unos
hermanos llamados brock gately se
jactaban de ser los mejores guerreros
del mundo y estaban dispuestos a
demostrarlo en una competencia la regla
era que cada familia debía fabricar tres
regalos para los dioses a los ivaldi les
correspondía crear una cabellera dorada
luego lo que visitó a brock y haití y
les comentó lo mismo con la diferencia
de que ahora explicaba los hijos de
world y eran los retadores pero brock y
haití no eran fáciles de engañar y
accederían a participar únicamente si lo
que ponía en juego su cabeza
literalmente sí brock y eight y ganaban
recibirían la cabeza de loki como premio
a lo que no le quedó más alternativa que
acceder y para salvarse debía asegurarse
de que los hijos de y baldi resultarán
victoriosos
ambos grupos comenzaron a trabajar el
tri ordenó a brock a tender el fuelle y
no detenerse por ningún motivo con los
tesoros se arruinarían en ese momento
una extraña mosca negra entró en la
habitación mientras se colocaba un trozo
de piel de cerdo en la fragua la mosca
picó a brock en la mano pero el enano ni
siquiera parpadeó luego mientras el tri
trabajaba con un bloque de oro la mosca
mordió a brock en el cuello el enano no
se detuvo por último y trip colocó un
trozo de hierro en la caldera esta vez
la mosca se posó justo en el párpado de
brock y lo mordió con todas sus fuerzas
por un breve instante las manos de
brocas soltaron el fuelle su último
tesoro no había permanecido en el fuego
el tiempo requerido lo que reapareció en
su forma habitual
contento por el fracaso de los enanos y
los acompañó a presentar sus regalos a
los dioses
no aquí presento primero los tesoros de
los hijos de infield y la cabellera
dorada se unió a la cabeza de shift y
continuó creciendo volviendo la más
radiante que antes
luego para odín el rey de los dioses una
magnífica lanza que podía atravesarlo
todo y finalmente para frei el dios de
la cosecha un pequeño paño que al
desdoblarse se convertía en un
formidable barco luego brock presentó
los tesoros que su hermano y él habían
fabricado para frei un jabalí y dorado
capaz de tirar de su carruaje y surcar
los cielos más rápido que cualquier
caballo para odín una argolla que
producía ocho más idénticas cada nueve
noches y para thor un martillo llamado
mi ovni y su empuñadura era muy corta y
luego que se burló del evidente defecto
pero entonces brock reveló cuáles eran
sus habilidades y òmnium nunca se
rompería nunca daría un golpe y siempre
regresaría a la mano de thor cuando él
lo lanzara a pesar de la corta
empuñadura todos los dioses concordaron
en que era el mejor los regalos al
recordar lo que estaba en juego lo que
intentó escapar pero todo lo detuvo
antes de que los enanos reclamara su
premio el astuto lo que señaló que
habían ganado su cabeza pero no su
cuello por ende no podían cortarlo a
regañadientes todos admitieron que lo
aquí tenía razón pero brock que iría al
último con el punzón de su hermano
perforó los labios de loki y le cosió la
boca para que así el dios tramposo ya no
pudiera engañar a nadie más los dioses
reconocieron lo irónico de la situación
pues fue gracias al engaño de loki que
obtuvieron sus valiosos tesoros incluso
el martillo de thor por el que el dios
es reconocido hasta la fecha
para conocer más mitos antiguos mire lo
que pasa cuando entregan a pandora una
caja mágica con una sola condición no a
abrirla nunca entérese que ocurre en
este vídeo y suscríbase a nuestro canal
para alimentar su curiosidad
ah
[Música]